use the appropriate formula on the
reference sheet
like we're telling you to use the
reference sheet um to find and then they
tell you all this stuff right
now have a look at all the information
this is the clue that tells you
which part of the reference sheet is
useful to you finding years
corrected two decimal places okay that's
less interesting
here it goes the time it takes for an
investment
so i just want to make sure i've got
full attention because
evidently we didn't do well in this
question
time it takes for an investment
to double in value at a rate of interest
and then it gives you all the details
about the interest so if you're looking
for an investment and it's got interest
applied to it
which is the only formula that tells you
anything about that
it's the compound interest formula right
that's it that's that's all that's
happening there's no annuity
there's no like i'm putting in extra
stuff right so the compound entrance
formula
is this guy do you agree like it's just
there
right okay so how do we use it
so i put that and then i put 1.05 in the
middle
okay all right so let's let's start to
unpack this right so the 1.05
is correct where does it come from the
answer is it comes from this part here
yeah five percent interest that's a one
plus a zero point
zero five so i agree with serena that'll
be a one point zero five and then
the rest okay no the rest where did that
come from all right well the first thing
i notice
is have a look at the question what is
the question asking us to find
like in words what's it asking for us
the number of years right
which part of this equation tells you
yes it's n right so this thing here
is the unknown so therefore it just it
just stays put
okay right does that make sense now then
when you have a look at the other part
a and p how do i work out those look at
the question again
it says we want an investment to do what
double in value so how does that
interact with this and this p what does
that tell us
very good yeah so this amount that you
want to end up on
you just want it to be double whatever
you started with do you agree
okay so we want 2p over here and this p
just stays put
because like i don't know how much they
invested it could be anything right
right so that's why i can divide both
sides by p you can do that because
p is not zero right so i get this
and then you're like what do i do with
this guy it's an exponential equation
but i want to make n the subject so what
do i do yeah
that's two p right what was two p this
guy here
yeah two times p p
right if you take one v no no no think
look again look again right what and i
even said it right what's the operation
that i did
to both sides yeah very good from here
all right so here i did not do any
subtraction
i did i did division right because
there's
p is a factor of both sides so i'm
dividing through
i'm not subtracting p this is p times
right so i have to divide through
so that's why divide through by p
divide three by p is that okay yeah i
still haven't got a clear answer what am
i gonna do with this to get
n yeah i'm gonna use log laws right well
i'm gonna use the definition of a log i
can write n equals
log base what 1.05 right 1.05 the base
becomes the base
and then there's only one number left
right now you need your change of base
law to actually
do that in your calculator because your
calculator doesn't have that so i would
write that as log
2 on log 1.05 right
the bottom goes to the bottom the top
goes to the top
and then you get and then you get what
14.2
all the stuff okay
if you didn't have this working yeah
well let's have a look
so this is two marks this question right
how important do you think the final
answer 14.21
is how important is that i mean it's
it's the answer right how how much do
you think it's worth
if you saw a student if you were marking
and you saw a student and they just
wrote down this
just out of thin air right what would
you give that
zero i probably i'd be i'd be wanting to
give them at least one like that's
that's come from somewhere
but i don't have any working to show how
they got there so i would say you'd need
to have at least some of it
right um this is this here is a pretty
critical line
this is a pretty critical line but
honestly i don't know how you get from
here to here without doing some of that
stuff in the middle anyway